avec bien sûr beaucoup de plaisir de
voir qu'on gagne quatre parlementaires
en Bourgogne dont de femmes pour
l'instant pour l'instant dont de femmes
c'est pas c'est pas mal parce que le la
présence féminine à l'Assemblée
nationale nous en parlions avec Emmanuel
coin reste bien en dessous de ce que
l'on pouvait espérer parce que quand je
vois le nombre de candidates féminine
sur l'ensemble des candidates même en
Bourgogne nous sommes loin des 50 %. euh
le deuxème chose c'est qu'on s'aperçoit
que finalement les chiffres s'inversent
euh quand je compare les chiffres de
2007 où il y avait environ nous avions
212 députés PS radicaux de gauche et
aujourd'hui apparemment les estimations
nationales sont aux environs de ce même
chiffre là donc on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
une averse une aversion des tendances et
moi j'ai envie de dire que on constate
tout de même malgré tout les premiers
résultats que vous venez de nous donner
dans Lyonne un bon report des voie du
Front National et on a un peu
l'impression qu'il y a une mutation
entre la droite et l'extrême droite qui
est en train de s'accélérer aujourd'hui
on l'avait déjà vu pour l'élection
présidentielle et j'ai un peu
l'impression que ça se confirme
aujourd'hui